Ngày Hai Thamay, Mưa lớn kéo dài sau khi bảo vý và quét qua đã về gia đủ đủ đêm trọng tại Philipein và Trung Quốc,
vô thang chục in người phải sớt tảnh, giù tầm báo không còn chức tiếp ảnh hơn.
Tại Philipein, thú đô mấy là và các khu vực lần cận chim trong nước lũ sọng một đêm với lớn,
mật nước sọng mariki na rất lên tới mệt và chạm bờ khiến hơn 200 người sống giọng bở sông phải dời khỏi nhà,
đến các nơi chủ hoàn tảm thời, thêm hâm lắm nghiêm người khác tại các thành phố như quay dòng và các lỗ cân cục vụ phải sớt tảnh.
Như chương học và cơ quan công quyền đã phải đẩm cửa là lượng kéo hộ đang tìm kiếm hàng người bị nước lỗ quần choi khi cố vực qua sống ở nấp.
Tần cầu, ý rất măng người thích bà, mấy cái mất tách tại Philipein, giọa anh hưởng của báo vý phà.
Chồng khi đó tại Trung Quốc, thành phố diang thật tình cálâm, vì nhận lượng mưa cực đuang lên tới 200, 200, 300 m左右 mẹ.
Gênh gặp lột trên dây rauc, chỉ quyết đe phương đã sớt tảnh hơn băng gình hai trong người dân,
quy đậu mmer hàng gình sau trăm dân viên hỗ trợ và sống như lượng hình gấp để ấn phó và khắc khủ hậu qua.
Các bạn video như là cho thấy nước lỗ quần quận quận đồ qua thành phố trong phía lượng trức năng hỗ trợ người dân.
Nóa ra các địa phương khiến năm trụ quốc của cuộc đẹp mình gặp lột, giọng mưa lượng sau khi bảo dịch đợi phá đổ bộ và hồng gông phôn hai mời thầm bài.